(air whooshing)
- [Announcer] This program
is a presentation of UCTV
for educational and
noncommercial use only.
(bright electronic music)
- Welcome to a Conversation
with History, I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is Jeremy Waldron,
who is University Professor
at New York University
School of Law.
He is the 2009 Tanner Lecturer
at the University of
California at Berkeley.
Jeremy, welcome to Berkeley,
welcome back to Berkeley.
- Thank you very much Harry,
it's very good to be here.
- Where were you born and raised?
- I was born and raised in New Zealand
in a little city called Invercargill
at the very south of New
Zealand's South Island.
- And looking back how
do you think your parents
shaped your thinking about the world?
- My father was a clergyman,
he was an Anglican minister
and I'm sure that made
an obvious difference
to my religion but he
was also philosophical
in his thinking and he had
qualifications in philosophy.
I used to follow him 'round
when I was a little kid
and it made a huge impact on me.
And my mother,
the debt is even greater
but it's harder to put into words.
It's an understanding of vulnerability
and the importance of
passion in everything I do.
- And around the dinner
table did these philosophical
discussions with your father continue?
- Well they did, there
were five of us children,
so a family of seven, so
philosophical might be
a generous time to describe the bickering
that would go on around the dinner table.
But I had an older brother
and an older sister,
and two younger sisters, and
the conversations there were
anarchic and wild and philosophical
and non-philosophical:
rock and roll music, fashion, gossip.
- And current events?
- [Jeremy] And current events.
- And how were you affected
by teachers as a young person
before college then after college?
- I had a number of very,
very strong male teachers
both at elementary school
and at high school.
I mean very, very strong
father figures I guess.
I went to an all boys high
school and loved it there.
You know I was on the
debate team and surrounded
with a cohort of equally nerdy
but equally high-spirited
boys.
And then at college
I had the benefit of one
of the loveliest philosophy departments
that you could possibly
imagine, small, intimate,
with some very, very good people.
There was one woman in
particular Gwen Taylor,
Gwen is still alive and
lives in New Zealand,
she's in her 90s now and I go and see her,
but she it was that introduced
me to political philosophy.
- And this was where now?
- This was the University of
Otago which is in Dunedin,
which is a city maybe 100
miles north of where I grew up.
- And then you went on to study the law?
- Yes that's right, I
studied philosophy first
and then I took a law degree;
there was a kind of overlap
and you could do a little
bit cross-crediting
between the two of them
and so I did a law degree
in New Zealand and then I went on to do
a doctorate in legal philosophy at Oxford.
- And was it hard to
make the choice between
being a practitioner,
being a legal philosopher,
or being a political philosopher,
or the latter two sort of overlap?
- The latter two overlap, they're
sort of areas that
overlap at their centers.
You know they don't just
overlap like a Venn diagram
at their margins, they're
like a couple of saucers
pressed up against one another.
So that choice wasn't hard
and actually the choice to do
legal theory rather than
legal practice wasn't hard.
It should have been harder than it was.
I should have thought more about it.
I regret in many ways
I never practiced law.
I would have like to have been a judge
as many people do
but it seemed natural to
go on into the area where
my talents were
useful and that really was
in legal and political philosophy.
- And what were the first
problems you grappled with,
basically, was there a
particular set of issues
that drew you from the beginning?
- Yes, there were two sets of problems.
One was issues about private property
and the justification of private property.
I began thinking about that quite early on
in my college days and then I
did a little bit of teaching
as a graduate student and my
doctoral work was on thinking
about John Locke, and
Hegel, and other people
about private property, and
then the other set of problems
that really invigorated
me, Harry, in my early days
in college were a set of
problems about the enforcement
of morality, a set of
philosophical problems about
the enforcement of morality
by the criminal law.
Problems that had arisen
primarily in Britain
and in New Zealand at the time
people were decriminalizing homosexuality,
decriminalizing prostitution,
in a variety of ways people
were asking should the law be
in the business of trying
to make us better people
or should the law be in the business
of simply protecting us from harm?
So it was a whole set
of issues I guess raised
by John Stuart Mill 150 years ago
but they were very live in
the late 60s and early 70s
and that was again an issue on which I cut
my teeth for political philosophy.
- Which it leads to a
question that I wanted
to address and for our audience here,
namely what does a philosopher do?
What is different from
a legal philosopher does
from what a political philosopher does?
You've already talked a little bit
about that but let's go on with that.
- Yes, both legal philosophers
and political philosophers
are interested in the
structures of the state
and they're interested in the
way state and law operate,
the way in which they constrain people,
the opportunities they offer,
the dangers that they offer.
Legal philosophers tend
to focus quite tightly
on how to read constitutions,
how to read statutes,
what the responsibilities of judges are,
how to think about the nature of law
and its relationship to
other normative systems.
Political philosophers
tend to grapple more
with particular problems,
whether it's problems
of social justice, or private property,
or the enforcement of morality,
or the prohibition on torture,
but also political
philosophers do think about
political institutions
like democracy and issues
about political institutions
that aren't strictly legal.
So as I say there is a
very, very big overlap
between the two but there are a great many
legal philosophers who
really have no training
in political philosophy
and I think that's a pity.
- It would seem to be a loss just
to the outside observer,
there's a natural synergy.
- There's a natural synergy.
It's exactly right and it ought
to be more common that it is
but an awful lot of people
who do legal philosophy,
they see their main philosophical home
as being moral philosophy
rather than political philosophy
and that means that they
take institutions, political
institutions, a little less
seriously than they should.
- Now what about the
skillset that is involved
in this kind of work, if
students were watching this,
I mean what might you
tell them about how they
would prepare for a career in this?
- Yes, I mean we do
philosophy by, we do it
on the shoulders of our predecessors.
So reading into the history of the subject
is hugely important; it's not
just antiquarian interest.
We do this in the company
of people like John Locke
and Thomas Hobbes, John
Stuart Mill, Aristotle,
Emmanuel Kant, this whole
canon, this whole pantheon
of great philosophers,
so reading your way into
their concerns, their
texts, their letters,
that's the first skillset,
and the other skillset
is a degree of patience
and that involves having
enough patience to be able to consider
an argument that you don't agree with
but to persevere with
the argument long enough
to get inside it and find
out what it involves.
That's one of the hardest things to do
but it's absolutely important
in political philosophy.
- And is there,
it seems, well first in terms
of the academic preparation, it seems
to be that one has to
have a sense of history.
- [Jeremy] Yes.
- And of the evolution
of society, this came out
very clearly in your
lectures yesterday on dignity
which we'll talk about in a minute,
so it's a broad-base set of knowledge.
So it's not just that you
know and can think about Locke
and Mill but also what they were coming
out of and how that has changed.
- I believe that's right.
Not everybody would say
that that was important
for political philosophy, I mean again,
I think you and I would agree
that this is tremendously
important as you say not
just to read the texts
as though they were written yesterday
but to understand the
differences and the movements
of history that frame the
problems that we deal with.
- Now, earlier when you were
talking about how you got
interested in morality
and the law you seemed
to be suggesting that
in a way the problems
that you focus on
you come to because of
times you're living in?
- [Jeffery] Yes.
- And what's going on
and such, talk about that
because that's very important.
Because in essence,
it's thinking about big problems
with reference to the past
but also very strongly
reference to the present and
clarifying what the thinking
should be, or might be, or alternatives.
- That's right, you certainly
come to these issues
through the problems that
you read in the newspapers,
the legislation that's being proposed,
the cases that are going
through the courts,
the controversies that are
flaring up in politics,
but you also, because you
come to it with your knowledge
of John Stuart Mill or
John Locke, you will
identify problems in a particular way,
you will see issues
that maybe the ordinary
newspaper reader won't see.
You say, aha, this is part of the problem
of political obligation where you say this
is a problem of the harm principle,
or this is an issue of
dignity and your reading
into the history of the
subject, it enables you
to identify, label, and relate issues
to one another in a distinctive way.
- And it seems that we have a greater
vacuum in this regard.
I don't mean in the academic
departments of philosophy
but we seem to have lost
the public intellectuals in
the way we had them before.
Is that fair?
What I'm getting at is not
a critique of philosophy
but a critique of public
discourse as we respond to events.
- Yes, I wouldn't have said that myself.
I think we've always had some people
who weren't purely within the academy
even in political philosophy, some people
who work more flamboyantly
outside the academy.
So for example, a man to whom
I owe a great intellectual debt,
Ronald Dworkin, he was my
doctoral supervisor at Oxford
and is now my colleague at NYU.
He's the sort of the essence
of a public intellectual.
He writes books, and
articles, and law reviews
and for university presses,
but he also engages with
great issues, particularly
about the Supreme Court
and great issues of rights in
the New York Review of Books
and in the newspapers, and
there are a number of people
like that who have a major presence.
So I don't think that we are
bereft of public intellectuals
in this way; it is certainly
true that there are a number
of people who are in political philosophy
and don't speak out on public issues.
There's a division of labor.
Everybody finds their comfort
level and their talents
take them to a particular
post in this division.
- Well I guess what I was implying is the,
I'm thinking about the cultural debasement
which seems to lead to a
situation where there isn't
sufficient recognition of
people who are out there.
- That's probably right and what we call
public intellectuals are probably writing
for a very small audience
and in that sense
there is some cultural debasement.
- What about creativity?
You're dealing with a
problem, you're looking back,
you're influenced by the present,
you're trying to clarify,
when does the light bulb go off?
Is there a general statement
or does the light bulb go off
in different ways with different problems?
- The light bulb goes
off in different ways
with different problems,
and you wait for it to go off and on
and you hope it will continue
to come on in various ways.
Again, it's a matter of patience.
You work your way into a problem.
You begin to make a little bit
of progress on various fronts
and then gradually you
can see the big picture
and you can begin to see
a distinctive, a new way
of stating the importance of an issue
or articulating some principle
that hadn't been clearly
articulated before
or giving an account of the trajectory
of some change that may not
have been there just before.
- Your Tanner lectures
on the Berkeley campus
have focused on the problem of dignity.
I thought it might be useful to talk about
what you said, walk you through that issue
and then maybe refer back
to some of the things
that we've just talked about.
So dignity, how do you come to that topic?
Why is it important?
- Right.
There's two questions.
One is why is it important
and why did I get interested in it?
It's important in the way that it figures
in the great human rights
charges in the universal
declaration of human rights
and the international
covenant on civil and political rights
in the Geneva conventions.
Dignity is all over the place.
It's cited as a ground
of rights and it's cited
as something that we have a right to.
So, it certainly is presenting itself,
it certainly is presenting
itself as though it were,
maybe not the be-all and end-all,
but certainly a very, very
important principle or value.
I came at it, Harry,
through some work I had done
on torture and on inhuman
and degrading treatment
of detainees which is an issue
that many of us found
to our shame that we had
to be working on over the
last five or six years.
Although some of that work
was public, intellectual work
on things that mattered
greatly in this country,
there was a need for a great
deal of background work
as well to try and get some
background intellectual
understanding of the values
that might have to be
invoked if we were to talk
intelligently and properly
about abuses of this sort.
- And it's interesting because
we're talking at a time
when the Torture Memos have come out,
made public that were written during
the administration of President Bush.
In focusing on this topic,
you're helping us clear
the brush in a way.
To give us a grounding in
addressing this problem.
- I think that's right.
What I haven't done in the Tanner lectures
is say very much about the torture issue.
I try to speak in more
general terms and often
in more upbeat optimistic
terms about what dignity is
rather than dignity being taken away.
But the concerns about the Torture Memos
are of course vividly
in my mind and I imagine
in the minds of many
people in the audience.
The important thing is
exactly what you say.
It's important to grapple
with the deep values
that are in the background here.
We do think that one of
the things about torture
is that it is a staggering
denial of human dignity.
We need to understand
that that's not rhetoric.
That's not just rhetoric.
It's attempting to communicate
a substantial idea.
So what I'm trying to do
is to say in a reasonably
upbeat way what that
idea may be and how it's
related to other things we care about.
- I'm gonna ask you
about that in one second
but I think it's worth
making the point that
when as the American
public has been reading
the memos this week,
this interview is taking
place in late April,
in reading them you're repulsed.
I mean you're just, you
don't have to have read
any philosophical treatises.
Just as a human being, you
intuitively have a sense
of dignity and what it is
and what has happened here.
But it's quite interesting
as I listen to your lectures
and want to talk about this now,
where does that sense
of dignity come from?
What is dignity as you begin this inquiry?
Help us, give us an
understanding of what it is
just in a few words.
- I think dignity, human
dignity, is a status
that we now accord to
every man, woman and child.
Dignity used to be a status
reserved for high nobles,
high functionaries of the state, bishops,
professors, statesmen and so on.
But it's now, it's still
a high-ranking status
but it's a high-ranking
status that we accord
to everybody.
It indicates that the
person has certain rights
so they can stand up for themselves.
That they are to be treated
as worthy of respect
and that they are to be given
deference and precedence.
They are to be given
some degree of authority
in their life decisions and the account
that they give of what they're doing.
So it's a way of insisting.
Talk of human dignity
is a way of insisting
that each person is to be taken seriously.
Each person is to be
taken seriously as though
they were a very important person.
Not just a commoner who
can be brushed aside
or somebody of no consequence.
So dignity is a way of
insisting that we all hold
a quite high rank in society
and we're entitled to respect
on that basis.
It has to do with how we're treated.
It also has to do with
how we bear ourselves,
how we stand up for ourselves.
Ultimately, it has to do with how we
enjoy our rights and
exercise them responsibly.
- Now, what you call a
transvaluation, I think.
Namely, when we move from
seeing the king in this way
to seeing every man that way.
These ideas in a way bubble
out over time through
changes of society, right?
I mean, what we're witnessing is
the emergence of a concept that reflects
the changing power structure
and the changing nature
of Western society over time.
- Yes, that's very true.
I mean, societies are obviously
become less aristocratic.
Less hierarchical, more
democratic in their organization.
Certainly true in the United States.
I don't mean more equal economically,
but more equal in terms of status.
So there are changes of that
sort which are very important.
But there are also changes,
Harry, in the moral imagination
and in how people think
of themselves and how they
think of others.
As my commentators, I've
had the good fortune
to have three very good commentators
for these Tanner lectures.
As they have reminded
me, the moral imagination
does wonderfully
complicated, ambiguous things
with the idea of dignity.
Sometimes, it makes fun
of the dignity of princes.
Sometimes, it makes fun of the pretensions
of the common man to have the
dignity of a prince or a duke.
Sometimes, it uses notes
of pathos and irony
to suggest that the
dignity of the common man
is actually higher than the
dignity of the noble lord.
And so it's not just changes in power
and changes in hierarchy.
It's also changes in
imagination, in literature,
in all the various ways
in which we think aloud
to each other about our
relations with one another.
- So you can then look to things like
the Judeo-Christian culture as introducing
the idea, or the Romantic
poets I think you mentioned.
- That's right, that's right yes.
I mean, there always was a tension
between an idea of human
dignity that was associated
with simply our being
created in the image of God
in the Judeo-Christian tradition,
and the idea of dignitas
attaching to particular offices
and ranks for example
in the Roman Republic.
And those two streams were in rather
uneasy relationship with one another.
What I see happening by the
middle of the 20th century,
is not that one of those prevailed
and the other withered
away, but rather the strand
that emphasized everybody being
created in the image of God
also took on some of the
sense of rank and hierarchy,
but only now generalized
rank and hierarchy.
- As you do this exploration and tease out
this story, it's very
clear, or let me assert
and you question what I'm saying,
that there is an element of
idealism in what you're doing.
So one has to step back and
say well he's not saying
it's always that way,
you are merely saying
that it's an idea that
is emerging over time
and that actually may be touched on to see
where we could even get
better in the future.
- That is certainly true.
It's exploring an ideal,
it's exploring the shape of an ideal.
The only quibble I would have Harry
with this term ideal, is
that that can sometimes
simply keynote a vague aspiration.
But many of the most important
dignitarian requirements
are presented as moral absolutes.
Now that also doesn't mean to
say that they're necessarily
reflected perfectly in what we do,
but they're not just aspirations.
They are strong, normative requirements.
And so the principal for
example that even the lowest
or the worst detainee is to be treated
in a way that's commensurate
with human dignity,
that's an ideal, but it's
not just an aspiration.
It's supposed to be a
requirement that people
should be punished if
they do not live up to.
- Now when you look for the foundations
of this concept, you pose two choices.
One, to look for it in morality
and the evolution of
morality as if it were given
down from on high as one of
the commandments or something,
and you really reject that and see the law
as being more important in
creating the foundation for this.
Talk a little about
that, 'cause it's a very,
it's surprising but after
one hears the argument
it makes a lot of sense.
- Yes, I mean I don't want
to disparage the sense
of morality associated with dignity,
but I do think people really
underestimate the resources
and the nature of argumentation
that goes on within the law.
Law isn't just about
rules or constitutions
or statutes or cases, law has deep
principles and policies
and values of its own.
And a lot of what we see with dignity
is an evolution within the legal framework
of important legal values.
Not values that the lawyers
had to abandon their own craft
and go over and talk to the theologians
and the moralists about,
abut ideas that were
endogenous to law and whose development
and dynamic of change
was endogenous to law.
- So it's an interlogic, partly
coming out of assumptions,
partly coming out of procedures,
that in other words,
it's suddenly, well no, I
don't want to say suddenly,
but over time dignity is emerging.
I think you used the word imminent
in legal processes and assumptions.
- I think that's exactly right.
I mean law changes, and the
very idea of a legal system
changes over time.
But I think we are evolving,
we have evolved now,
perhaps over the last three
or four hundred years,
we have evolved now to a situation where
distinctively legal processes,
distinctively legal
institutions imminently convey
a multitude of ideas about human dignity.
Not just by laying down
certain rules about dignity,
but by insisting that
people must be heard,
by allowing people to give
an account of themselves,
by allowing people to make
arguments on their own behalf,
by again treating them seriously
and insisting that they must
not be dismissed with contempt.
- And so through all of
this, it's almost as if
a recognition is there even
if you have to pull it out
in a sense of putting
these things together.
- This is true, and I think this
happens in law all the time.
We don't just argue
about the interpretation
of rules and constitutions and statutes,
we also try to recognize
deeper principles,
see important normative
passions in the law
that may not be visible
to the first glance,
but require you to dive
deep into the resources
of the legal system and make connections
that wouldn't be superficially evident.
- Now in making your
argument you put on the table
what morality and moral
philosophy had to offer
and you show a movement there
from focusing on the noble
to common man, making it universal,
and then you focus on the law
and we've just talked about this.
Where is power in this?
And the reason I raise this is because,
when we get to torture,
it seems to be that
power enters the equation
and can move us forward and set us back.
- Yes.
We live in a world
where power is organized
and exercised in certain
ways and not in other ways.
Power is organized and exercised
through political systems.
And through the frameworks
of law, so we very rarely
see naked power being exercised.
And even, Harry, in the
distressing business
of the Torture Memos, what
was striking was an attempt,
a perverted attempt, but
an attempt nonetheless
was made to try and show
how torture could take
its place in a legally
justified set of responses.
I think it was a
disastrously inept argument.
And it was a grave problem
that law was being tainted
with this business of torture,
but what was remarkable was
that those who were engaged
in abusive interrogation didn't just say
let's do this and worry
about the law later,
they dragged the law into the
torture chamber with them.
They sought, not just legal cover
but they sought a legal framework
for what they were doing.
And that was both distressing
but in a backhanded way, quite inspiring.
It shows that even at its most abusive
and at its most extreme,
you never see naked power,
what you see in political
life is politicized,
legalized, institutionalized power.
- And in fact you made the argument
that it's an argumentation
and one of the processes in the law
that allows for this sense
of dignity to emerge.
But of course the whole
process of creating these memos
was to make them secret where
they couldn't be argued about.
So in a way, this is
another proof of your point,
that they felt the need to do it,
and maybe they sensed that these arguments
would be dismissed, so
they kept it secret.
- Yes, I suppose that's true.
As far as we know, the memos
were produced at a time
when a number of people, particularly
in the Central Intelligence Agency
had become very nervous
about their possible
criminal and legal liability.
Some people, some quite
high-ranking people
had been tortured to death,
and there were a number of operatives
who were very nervous about their position
and wanted to know what
their legal position was.
So it was important to the agencies
to get some clarification.
I thought they were entitled to better
and rather stricter
advice than they received,
but the advice was circulated
to the agencies that needed it.
It's just that the public was intended
to be cut out of the process.
- Right, but in different
parts of the government
when it was circulated and criticized,
they were removed from circulation.
- This is true, but you have to remember,
we had Torture Memos circulating in public
and same as that form
no doubt, on the web,
really from 2003, 2004 onward.
The memos that have been
produced and released
in the last
three or four weeks were
a second wave of memos.
But some of the most egregious work,
the Bybee Memo drafted by
John Yoo of this university.
Some of the other Torture
Memos were reasonably
common knowledge to those
who appeared to look for them
certainly by late 2004.
- Now this raises an interesting question,
you've worked a lot, you have
a book on liberal rights,
you've thought a great deal about
the rights that have
emerged from out tradition.
You're obviously working now on dignity,
and it's this problem
that terrorism poses.
Looking at the Torture Memos,
we're looking at the mistaken
response to terrorism.
But terrorism itself is a problem
because it seems to want to fight in a way
that undermines many
of the central features
of what has become this
tradition that we believe in.
Talk a little about that,
because it's a new kind of adversary
that challenges us in our commitment
to the values that have adopted.
- So let's put it this way,
in armed conflict, in
warfare, there is often
some falling short of
international law standards
by armies and armed forces of all sorts.
But terrorism is a military doctrine
that holds the whole panoply of the laws
and customs of armed conflict in contempt.
It's an explicit turning of one's back
of the norms that we have introduced,
the fragile norms that we have introduced
to try and mitigate the
barbarity of conflict.
Terrorism claims to
succeed or hopes to succeed
by deliberately violating, denigrating,
and smashing the very rules
that we have introduced
to try and allow some sort of modicum
of compassion, mitigation,
in armed conflict.
And terrorism is wrong primarily
because it is murderous
and it does hold people's
rights in contempt,
but it's wrong also because
it holds this fragile
necessary enterprise of regulating
armed conflict in contempt.
As I say, armies, whether
it's the British army
or the American armed forces
or the Israeli defense forces
or the security forces of
the Palestinian authority,
these organizations
sometimes break the laws
of armed conflict, but they
haven't turned their back
on the whole enterprise
in the way that terrorist
organizations have, and I think that needs
to be said very clearly.
The other thing is that
terrorism involves the same
instrumentalization of
terror that torture involves.
I'm not saying that
this means that torture
is an appropriate response
to terrorism, it's not.
It's not an appropriate
response to anything.
But nevertheless, part of the,
by understanding what's wrong
with torture, we can also understand
what's wrong with terrorism.
- Now,
I guess what then would be
the way we should look
at an appropriate response to terrorism?
I mean, clearly we're
learning the many mistakes
that were made, how in a way
the Bush memos suggest a course
that takes a liberal society
and makes it like the
other, whom you've just
described quite adequately.
Where, how should we think about that?
Because I think one of the things,
one agenda that President
Obama is trying to set
is to say well we don't do this.
So help us understand what
is an appropriate response.
- Right, I think the first
thing to do is to distinguish
the particular evil of
terrorism from some things
that are often confused with it,
namely for example insurgent
movements, irregular forces.
The Taliban for example is a strong,
dangerous insurgent movement.
It often engages in
terrorism, it certainly gives
shelter to terrorist organizations,
but it's position in Afghanistan
and to a certain extent,
its position in Pakistan
is that of a particular
fanatical insurgent movement.
So it's very important I
think to distinguish between
how we wage war against irregular forces
and that sort of struggle
and how we deal with the
suicide bombers, the Al Qaedas,
the 9/11 terrorists who
were engaged directly
in terrorism properly so-called.
I don't doubt that it is
necessary to fight both battles,
but dealing with the people
who are going to plant bombs
in public places is somewhat different
from just engaging in the
regular, irregular warfare
in Afghanistan and Pakistan.
- And what emerges as we
think back about the last
eight years is really a
lack of clarity on the part
of the Bush administration
as to who the adversary was,
confusing national liberation
movements with global terrorists
who are the Al Qaeda brand.
- Yes, I think that's right.
And I think it comes
back to this ambiguity
between irregular warfare and terrorism.
When I say that terrorism
turns its back on the laws
and customs of armed conflict,
I have in mind primarily
the norm that says you are
not to attack civilians.
So when,
resistance forces,
insurgent forces in Iraq
or Afghanistan attack a
platoon of American soldiers
its very bad and it's shameful
and it shouldn't be done,
but that's not turning
one's back on the laws
of armed conflict,
that's attacking soldiers
in a neo-military situation.
Terrorism, that's not terrorism.
Terrorism is this other thing
of deliberately attacking
civilians in order to sew
a certain amount of panic.
So these distinctions are important.
It still doesn't tell you how to answer
the question that you pose
which is how do you deal
with terrorism?
And I think you try to do
the law enforcement path
as far as you can.
You try to avoid making things worse.
Sometimes people think
something must be done,
even if it makes things
worse, we must respond.
And it's the beginning
of wisdom to realize
that sometimes all you can do
is avoid making things worse.
- I think this might be useful
to talk a little again about
power, because the norms
we're talking about, especially dignity,
emerge both out of international covenants
and out of national laws, basically.
And one of the interesting things about
the Bush administration was it starting
with the assumption that
all international law
could be put aside,
almost all international,
much of what had become
part of the international
law of covenants, treatment
of prisoners of war and so on.
What I
want to ask about is the
fragility of the basis
of the concepts that should
guide us as we approach
this new problem.
- Yes, I think that a
fragility in international law
has been exposed in this period.
One of the interesting things is the way
in which international law operates.
It very seldom tries to
do all the work by itself.
What it usually does is
it works hand in hand
with national law, so for
example we have the convention
on torture to which this country
along with lots of other
countries is a signatory.
That's a treaty, multi-lateral treaty
and has the status of international law.
But that treaty requires those signatories
to pass anti-torture legislation.
So we have an anti-torture statute,
and that's American law, and so we work
with two layers, all the time.
And international law
does that all the time,
not just on human rights treaties,
but it does it on civil aviation treaties
and postal conventions and so on.
You have one layer where you
have the international law
provisions and then you
have a layer below that
with the various national legal systems
try to echo each other and echo the
international law provision.
And at its best that's how
international law works,
rather than, I mean
it's rather like we have
the human rights
conventions, but we also have
our own constitution.
And our own constitution does in its way
much of what the international
human rights conventions
try to do in their way.
So we have a phrase for
that, it's one of the ugliest
phrases in political philosophy,
but it's called dual positivization.
Two levels of positivization.
We positivize the law at
the international level,
and we try to positivize the
same law at the national level.
- And its very clear
that there's a synergy
between the two as we
see threats of invoking
universal jurisdiction
to some of the former
Bush administration officials as a way
to push the national system
to undertake some sort of inquiry.
- I think that's right, I mean I think
that's very unfortunate if that becomes
the primary way in which
these abuses are dealt with.
The United States generally in its history
has had a creditable ability to be able
to remedy its own shortcomings.
And we should expect that
of every national system,
and every well-disciplined set
of military and security forces.
That they can use their own military law
and their own criminal law if
need be to deal with abuses.
We shouldn't have to rely
on some Spanish judge
or the International Criminal
Court to do these things.
And I think it's wrong for
scholars, however concerned
they are about torture and other things
to become too intoxicated
with universal jurisdiction.
It's very exciting when it happens,
as it was in the Pinochet
case for example.
But it can't possibly be the
front line mode of enforcement.
- What do you think should
be a path of inquiry
with regard to this matter?
I say path of inquiry,
something seems to be
done, in other words,
to close the case on this
issue, to have a sense
that this was done and
it was wrong to do it
for these reasons.
There has to be an inquiry, a tribunal,
a truth commission, whatever.
Do you have any thoughts about that?
Because obviously politics
interfaces with this
and if you go for criminal prosecution
within the country, it may undermine
other items on the agenda that
have nothing to do with this.
- That's perfectly possible.
And if you go for criminal prosecution,
I'm not saying you
should or you shouldn't,
but if you do go for criminal prosecution,
then the political
reasons for opposing that
may translate too quickly
into political reasons
for opposing the whole torture regime.
In 1973,
Great Britain was accused
of using of using torture
in northern Ireland, certain
methods of interrogation
remarkably similar to some
of the ones that were used
in Guantanamo Bay.
And they were introduced
as a matter of policy,
and the government of the United Kingdom
shortly after exception
was taken to these,
made a public announcement
saying we have carefully
considered what we did, and
we will never do it again.
And we give an undertaking
to the national community
that we will never do it again.
I don't know that they
held any particular people
criminally responsible,
and it may or may not
be a good idea in certain
circumstances to do that.
It's probably a good idea just to proceed
in the way that we are
proceeding at the moment,
which is that the office of
professional responsibility
within the government is investigating
the low level of legal work done by people
in the Office of Legal
Counsel and elsewhere.
And that's a matter of making
sure that the professional
standards remain high,
this was a great lapse
in professional standards.
I don't know whether we particularly need
a truth and reconciliation commission
or anything like that.
We need to know what
happened, but we actually do
have a reasonably clear
understanding of what happened.
What we need primarily is to concentrate
on this announcement to the world
and that in no circumstances
will we go down this path again.
- What would you like to see,
the philosophical discourse
on issues like dignity
contribute to, this process of coming
to terms with what we've done,
and how does that happen?
- Yes, the one thing that
I found very very hard
in the philosophical discourse
was to get a clear sense
of a moral absolute, that
there were certain things
that were simply not to be
done in any circumstances
no matter what the advantages may accrue,
no matter what the
temptations and the anger
and the panic that was background to them.
And it proved much much
harder than I thought
to convey the point within
modern philosophical vocabulary
and modern philosophical ideas
that there were certain absolute
prohibitions on certain conduct.
The law can make sense of these partly
because we can simply announce
an absolute prohibition,
and torture is absolutely
prohibited as a matter
of national and international law,
there's no emergency exception, nothing.
But philosophically,
it revealed that we are
a little bit bankrupt so far as the ideas
that are necessary to make sense
of an absolute prohibition,
even in the face of
overwhelming temptation.
I believe personally this is partly
because we've turned our back
on certain religious ideas
associated with morality,
but that's a separate one.
- Now the
answer on the other
side is always the use,
misuse of the ticking bomb scenario
and the extent to which that has been
embedded in the popular
culture is quite extraordinary.
How do we get beyond that?
At one level it's very easy to dismiss,
but on another level it
really holds the imagination
even though what has
gone on here has moved
very much beyond the ticking bomb.
The ticking bomb situation one might not
want to have rules for,
and it's all just done
very quickly and then over.
But here the process was bureaucratized.
- Yes, it was.
I don't want to subscribe that
we should just let it happen
but not bureaucratize it,
although that's attractive
to a number of people.
The ticking bomb scenarios generally
just present arithmetic.
They present a large
number of lives at stake
on the one hand and a
considerable amount of pain
for one person on the other hand.
And if the argument is not accepted,
then they double the number
of lives on the one hand
to justify the pain on the other hand.
The ticking bomb story is just
arithmetic with illustrations.
The real point is to be able to understand
what might be at stake in torture
in a way that's not
revealed by consequential
calculations of this sort.
And that's where I think
dignity is very important,
that dignity is not
just a certain aesthetic
or a posture that somebody might value,
but that dignity has to
do with the fundamental
sacred status of each human being.
And so we need to understand,
begin to understand,
even in the ticking bomb scenario,
that the proposal is to
do something sacrilegious,
effectively, to a human being.
Sometimes I find it useful to say,
in the debates I've had on this,
that we all have some blocking point
or some stopping point which we would use
to resist even the
ticking bomb hypothetical.
There are many people
who claim that they would
be prepared to support torture to stop
a ticking bomb from going off.
Would they be prepared to support rape
to stop a ticking bomb going off?
Or the raping of a terrorist's children
to stop the ticking.
Usually some people will, as it were,
draw the line somewhere.
They will say no, this is too abhorrent,
this is too much of an abomination.
My view is that we should draw that line
roughly where the law has always insisted
that it be drawn, at torture.
But if people, it's almost as though now
I'm playing the game from the other side,
just as the ticking bomb
people multiply the number
of possible victims to try and
make their rhetorical point.
I'm making my rhetorical
point by saying even
the most hard-nosed consequentialist
is gonna find some practice
that he will regard
as too abominable to be supported,
even with a million
people strapped to a bomb.
- I hear you suggesting that
we're missing what
religion might have wrought
on some of these moral issues,
that somehow a vacuum as been created.
Am I correct in hearing that?
And what do we do about that?
And how does a secular world
where law is so important
make note of what is lost there
and be informed by it?
- It has to acknowledge the loss,
I think is the first thing.
You can't artificially recreate it
if people don't have religious faith,
then there's no way in which
you can force them back to it.
But you try to give
some secular surrogates.
I mean I believe myself
that torture is sort of
a way in which the demonic
enters human affairs.
But you can give a sort of
a secular account of that.
I believe that,
the security that might
be sustained by torture
is a security not worth having,
and that we should be
disgraced rather than enjoy it.
And I think we can state that idea
in secular terms.
I believe that there are some things worse
than death and the threat of death.
And that sometimes the response
to a ticking bomb scenario
is we should be prepared to
die rather than to do this.
It's easier to say that from
a religious point of view,
but it's not wholly unimaginable
from a secular point of view.
So,
the hardest thing to convey is the sense
that there is something
ontologically sacred
about the human individual,
and that no matter what the temptation
or no matter how bad the human individual,
there is some respect still owing.
And this is not an argument
against punishing terrorists.
It's not even argument
against executing terrorists.
It's insisting nevertheless that you must
be prepared to proceed
with the recognition
that the person you are
proposing to try and punish,
to apprehend and to stop,
to interdict and perhaps to kill,
is nevertheless a child of
God like everybody else.
- Do you, one final question,
do you, as somebody who's worked on
thinking thorough the rights and liberties
that are part of our tradition,
do you feel that we're gonna have to do
careful thinking in the future
as we respond to this security threat
that we've been talking about,
that we're gonna have to make adjustments?
And will we have to bring the
same kind of thought process
that we brought to this torture issue
to other issues such as
freedom of the press,
free speech and so on?
- It's conceivable Harry, I
don't think we can rule it out,
we shouldn't assume that
any given set of rights
or any given set of
the way in which rights
have been calibrated in the past
is guaranteed to be
suitable for the future,
or even that we have got a right.
There are a number of
issues where we still argue.
Should hate speech be prohibited
or does free speech protection
preclude that, for example?
And those are cases
where we are not yet sure
that we've got it right about rights.
Some of those issues are
background and enduring,
some of them are circumstantial,
so I don't want to rule anything out.
But it matters enormously
that when we think about
adjusting rights or adjusting
our understanding of rights
in the light of new threats to security,
that we must understand that it is rights
that we're adjusting, and
that's not a small thing.
These are very very serious constraints
designed to do a very serous job,
and they're not supposed
to be simply responsive
to issues of social convenience.
And they are supposed to
be informed by a logic
of equality and by these
ideas of dignity and respect.
We must take care even when
we're juggling them and recalibrating them
for a more dangerous
world, that we bear in mind
that these are the primary ways
in which we protect human dignity.
- Well on that note Jeremy,
I want to thank you very much
for coming on our program,
coming back to the campus
and delivering the Tanner
lectures, thank you.
- It's a delight to be here
Harry, thank you very much.
- And thank you very much for joining us
for this Conversation with History.
(light electronic music)